[Musica]
quanti di voi conoscono un codice iban
hanno usato per inviare un bonifico
sulla propria banca online
quanti di voi mentre cercano di
prenotare un volo aereo usano i codici
internazionali degli aeroporti e lei nfc
o mxp quanti hanno mai usato un codice
mav per pagare un bollettino online
sono certo che la maggior parte di voi
conosce questi codici li ha già usate
più di una volta dal suo smartphone dal
suo browser
la cosa interessante che questi codici
multi altri codici un po difficili che
usiamo tutti i giorni dalle nostre app
non sono nati per essere usati da noi
come utenti e consumatori finali dei
servizi
al contrario codici e procedure come
fare un bonifico in banca o prenotare un
biglietto aereo in origine sono state
pensate progettate per essere gestite da
operatori professionisti di solito
impiegati preparati e formati
appositamente per fornire servizi al
pubblico in un negozio o in un'agenzia è
infatti fino a pochi anni fa inviare un
bonifico bancario o prenotare un volo
aereo non erano attività che facevamo da
soli oggi questi servizi sono diventati
digitali tutto si fa comodamente con uno
smartphone
oggi sappiamo come usare un codice iban
un mar
e siamo felici di aver imparato a usarli
perché per noi diventato tutto molto più
comodo risparmiamo un sacco di tempo
chi vorrebbe oggi cancellare le app dal
suo telefono tornare indietro alla carta
e alle file
nessuno pensiamo ora il commercio
elettronico
seguiamo una promozione navighiamo un
catalogo facciamo ricerca curiosiamo
scoviamo immagini leggiamo i commenti
poi alla fine scegliamo dei prodotti
componiamo un ordine infine lo inviamo
pagando online chi è questa su internet
fa tutto questo con uno smartphone e con
un pc in totale autonomia senza nessun
aiuto e senza nessuna assistenza per
molti lo shopping online è un'esperienza
semplice e anche divertente
in realtà dietro un interfaccia grafica
un negozio dal punto di vista tecnico è
una piattaforma complessa ma noi non ci
accorgiamo di questa complessità
se tutto è fatto bene
questi sono esempi comuni di tutti i
giorni che raccontano bene cosa succede
quando un servizio da analogico diventa
digitale e questo è anche uno dei nostri
punti chiave online l'utente si serve da
solo
questo è uno dei principi fondamentali
di una buona user e spinesi digitale
ognuno deve essere messo nelle migliori
condizioni per interagire da solo con la
piattaforma tecnologica
dobbiamo poter trovare informazioni
completamente una situazione in totale
autonomia senza assistenza e senza
complicazioni
a prescindere dalla complessità della
tecnologia utilizzata e dei processi
sottostanti
questo principio è alla base del
successo di tante app e tanti siti web
usati da milioni di utenti tutti i
giorni in tutto il mondo
ora pensate quante volte vi è capitato
di abbandonare una transazione una
procedura con un'app con un sito web
perché era troppo complesse a poco
chiara o perché avete incontrato un
problema tecnico
sono problemi che succedono a tutti e
succedono in continuazione
chi gestisce le piattaforme digitali
combatte tutti i giorni con questi
problemi e fa il possibile per rendere
l'interazione più facile per i suoi
clienti perché ne va della sua
sopravvivenza come servizio
ecco adesso
7 quante volte avete lasciato la
navigazione a metà o non siete riusciti
a completare una transazione o una
procedura su un portale della nostra
pubblica amministrazione
io sono un designer il mio lavoro ea
progettare servizi digitali sono un
esperto di user experience e di
trasformazione digitale
questi esempi che vi ho appena fatto non
sono scelti a caso ho passato gran parte
della mia vita professionale alla
progettazione di piattaforme digitali
banche assicurazioni compagnia air e
servizi di vendita online è molto alto
l'obiettivo fondamentale di chi fa il
mio lavoro è esattamente questo rende le
piattaforme tecnologiche facili efficaci
e fruibili per le persone credevano
usare buona parte del mio lavoro è
basato su una continua ricerca sui
fattori umani che influenzano il modo in
cui le persone interagiscono con la
tecnologia quali sono i bisogni di chi
la deve usare quali sono le sue
difficoltà come superarle la cosa
interessante di questa continua ricerca
sui problemi degli utenti e che nel
corso degli anni abbiamo imparato che le
difficoltà maggiore non sono dovute
soltanto la tecnologia e all'interfaccia
grafica spesso sul fronte della tutela e
marg ohno problemi che hanno radici più
profonde sono nei processi
nell'organizzazione dei servizi come
sono organizzati integrati dati come
girano le informazioni nel corso degli
anni ho ascoltato e studiato centinaia
di persone che mi raccontavano e
mostravano il loro problemi mentre
cercavano di usare un portale è un'app
ho ascoltato tantissime storie di siti
web confusi da navigare molto felice che
non funzionano moduli che non si
caricano carrelli della spesa
abbandonati e pagamenti va a lasciati a
metà
immagino siano storie familiari per
molti di voi tutte queste storie sono
molto importanti perché ci aiutano non
solo a capire cosa non funziona le
nostre piattaforme e come migliorare i
servizi digitali che progettiamo sono
fondamentali perché ci aiutano a vedere
la tecnologia alle piattaforme
tecnologiche
dal punto di vista più importante quello
di chi davvero utilizza questi servizi e
della sua esperienza d'uso reale perché
da lì che bisogna partire
e qui arriviamo al nostro tema
egovernment quando si parla di servizi
pubblici in italia si parla spesso anche
di digital divide divario digitale
ricordiamo brevemente cos'è in parole
semplici il divario digitale indica la
disparità tra i cittadini che riescono
ad accedere a internet e godere dei
benefici dell'innovazione digitale e
quelli che per qualche motivo non ci
riescono o non possono il livello
digitale è un problema serio per il
nostro paese non è un problema solo
italiano è comunque un problema che ha
impatti sociali economici culturali
importanti e fonti di disuguaglianza e
ritardi perché lo subisce il livello
digitale è uno svantaggio sociale
uno degli esempi più evidenti di digital
divide il divario tecnico
infrastrutturale cioè l'effettiva
disponibilità di connettività a banda
larga sul territorio
immagino sia una cosa che non ha bisogno
di tante spiegazioni questo è un
problema ancora molto grande per il
nostro paese e molti lo conoscono anche
da vicino il decida di vahid indica
anche un altro problema un divario
culturale cioè la mancanza di conoscenze
competenze necessarie alle persone per
usare in modo efficiente gli strumenti
tecnologici e fruire dei servizi online
in modo soddisfacente
quando si parla di servizi pubblici e
via internet esibisce spesso a discutere
anche di digital divide di
alfabetizzazione digitale dei cittadini
come istruire le persone usare un
computer navigare su internet per
esempio come usare un portale una
pubblica amministrazione come quello
dell'inps e dell'agenzia delle entrate
quello di un comune dove dovete gestiva
una pratica paghiamo una multa
effettivamente a vedere i dati il
problema sembra piuttosto serio secondo
il rapporto digital economy and society
index rapporto daisy della comunità
europea nel 2020 l'italia risulta
letteralmente tra gli ultimi paesi in
europa per utilizzo dei servizi di
egovernment siamo in fondo alla
classifica con soltanto il 32 per cento
dei cittadini che hanno usato almeno una
volta qualche servizio pubblico online
contro una media europea del 67 per
cento più del doppio e tutte molto più
alte nei paesi del nord europa come
vediamo dal grafico il gap e dell'e
government e non è solo verso le medie
europee ma anche verso le medie di
utilizzo dei servizi digitali anche in
italia nel nostro paese gli italiani
fanno online shopping nei social network
si informano online usano l'internet
banking e league ovviamente rimane
sempre costantemente indietro il metallo
a digitare le nostre amministrazioni non
manca anzi negli ultimi anni c'è stata
una fioritura di nuovi portali e servizi
on line ormai sono centinaia
la volontà e l'impegno ci sono malgrado
questo se guardiamo ai tassi di adozione
league over mentre nel nostro paese è
ancora fortemente in ritardo
qual è la ragione di questo ritardo come
spiegavo prima c'è chi pensa che il
problema sia che gli italiani non sono
pronti non sono cose abbastanza esperti
nell'uso del computer e internet e
quindi non usano i portali pubblici
la colpa dunque è del digital divided
questa spiegazione non mi convince
penso sia un modo per paralizzare gli
utenti dei servizi giustificando per
fama sport poco soddisfacenti e spesso
anche fallimenti con una presunta
incapacità degli utenti usa la
tecnologia ma siamo davvero sicuri che
il problema è insegnare alle persone
come navigare un portale internet
non credo che sia così a vedere i numeri
generali l'italia non è messa così male
secondo rapporto daisy 2020 che abbiamo
visto poco fa il 74 per cento degli
italiani sono utenti abituali internet
siamo sotto la media europea ma c'è
quater italiani sono online il nostro
paese tra i primi 10 al mondo per
diffusione di smartphone per abitante ho
mai nelle case di italiani ci sono più
smartphone che televisore gli iscritti a
facebook sono oltre 36 milioni e un
numero più o meno simile usa wazza
provvede un video su youtube almeno una
volta al mese in media gli italiani
passano online oltre sei ore al giorno
in tutto questo la pandemia comportato
una ulteriore accelerazione verso
digitale nel corso del 2020 il consumo
internet in italia aumentato mediamente
le 50 per cento con picchi ancora più
alti sulla rete mobile oltre un milione
di persone per la prima volta ha
comprato ordinato qualcosa online
secondo i dati della banca d'italia le
transazioni conta 3 sul totale delle
transazioni con carta di credito sono
passate dal 35 per cento prima della
pandemia
al 55 per cento gli acquisti ecommerce
sono passati dal 25 al 40 per cento
delle transazioni di capperi solito è
anche sul lato dei servizi pubblici
digitali ci sono stati passi avanti gli
utenti con un account speed
sono ormai venti milioni con 100 milioni
di accessi registrati solo nel primo
trimestre 2020
insomma dobbiamo migliorare ma il
digitale nostro paese è un fenomeno di
massa
cosa ci dicono questi numeri ci dicono
che il problema forse non è insegnare
agli italiani usare il computer la
tecnologia quando analizziamo la bassa
propensione all'utilizzo dei servizi di
egovernment e in italia
incontriamo un digital divided diverso
quello della pubblica amministrazione
quando interagiscono con i servizi
pubblici di italiani restano cittadini
analogici
il problema non è la laurea scarsa
confidenza con la tecnologia ma la bassa
qualità dell'offerta e delle esperienze
ad uso dei nostri servizi on line
molti portali pubblici sono poco usati
perché purtroppo sono progettati e
realizzati male non sono utilizzati dai
cittadini comuni a questo nuovi volti
all'inizio abbiamo fissato un principio
semplice ma molto importante online
l'utente deve potersi servire da solo in
piena autonomia
cosa che avviene normalmente su tutte le
piattaforme commerciali
ebbene i numeri ci dicono molto
chiaramente che per i servizi pubblici
digitali questo è ancora un problema
enorme
se facciamo il confronto con gli
standard and user experience e di
efficienza dei servizi privati che
usiamo tutti i giorni ci rendiamo conto
che siamo ancora lontani da questi
standard
c'è un gap enorme il paese lo stesso le
persone sono le stesse vanno sì social
comprano online s'informano online usa
mente nel banking ma quando incontrano
un portale pubblico si comportano in
modo diverso
chiaramente il problema non è sul lato
della domanda e sul lato dell'offerta
per superare questo di weiden serve un
approccio nuovo quel punto non è
soltanto il front end di un portale non
stiamo parlando di avere interfacce
grafiche in coordinate e ben disegnate è
certamente importante c'è un team che
sta facendo un ottimo lavoro ma non
stiamo parlando soltanto di questo
dietro di interfaccia ci sono ancora
tante complicazioni e problemi
strutturali da risolvere per
semplificare davvero l'esperienza dei
nostri portali pubblici
il passo in avanti che dobbiamo fare è
la semplificazione e l'integrazione dei
servizi dei processi digitali
sottostanti
partendo da una nuova idea di
piattaforma digitale unificata e
centrata su cittadino sono pienamente
cosciente che la nostra pubblica
amministrazione una macchina molto
grande e molto complessa che fa
tantissime cose diverse e
l'amministrazione sul territorio sono a
loro volta tantissime ma cittadino e uno
i suoi bisogni di base sono sempre gli
stessi informarsi scaricare documenti
avviare seguire delle pratiche
completare delle transazioni e cose
simili
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare alle
esperienze del cittadino digitale in
modo integrato
semplificando unificando i servizi
processi e dati già a partire dal back
end dobbiamo superare tutta la
frammentazione che c'è tra i singoli
portali e gli sportelli digitali non
sono gli utenti che devono girare tra i
portali sono i dati che devono girare
solo in questo modo possiamo
semplificare l'interazione con tutta la
macchina amministrativa nei paesi del
nord europa dove league ovviamente
funziona e funziona bene e viene usato
la filosofia è fornire ai cittadini uno
sportello unico per gestire le pratiche
più comuni senza dover necessariamente
passare attraverso portali esportare
diversi dove magari le stesse cose si
fanno con logiche e con procedure
diverse
il futuro della sanità delle
amministrazioni locali dell'istruzione e
del welfare e di tanti altri servizi
alla collettività sarà sempre più un
futuro digitale in futuro che dovrà
essere fondato su un eco sistema
pubblico di servizi interconnessi
inclusivo davvero universale è centrato
sul cittadino dobbiamo avere una
piattaforma integrata progettata per
permettere a tutti di informarsi e di
servizi da soli in modo facile veloce ed
efficiente un servizio pubblico
costruito in questo modo un servizio
pubblico più giusto e più utile e
soprattutto è meglio attrezzato per
rispondere ai bisogni della società e
per favorire la crescita del paese
questo è un requisito fondamentale per
permettere a tutti di essere davvero
pienamente cittadini digitali